des affiches comme celle ci il y en a de
plus en plus aux abords de l'autoroute
117 signe d'une réalité de plus en plus
difficile pour les employeurs
au centre de villégiature de mont
tremblant le manque de personnel est
flagrant seulement en juillet on
estimait qu environ 400 postes étaient
toujours disponibles qu'on n'a pas
réussi à combler ça représente tout près
de 140 mille heures de travail qui n'ont
pas été comblées c'est du jamais vu ce
que jamais vu cela peut nuire une même
doit vous venez pas s'est pas déclaré
pendant la pandémie elle s'est accentuée
0 plus tard ce matin je parle encore
avec des gens d'un commerce jeu ça
allait me chercher mon petit café puis
jusqu'à mars avoir pu me répond me
rapporter encore formés sur les genoux
et nous avons eu quand même des données
record cet été au niveau de nos
commerçants haut niveau au tennis mais
il n'en demeure pas moins qu'on ne pas
site personnel pour faire le travail
résultat la majorité des commerces doit
fermer une deux parfois trois journées
par semaine on a perdu des centaines et
des centaines de milliers de dollars
donc deux personnes ça fait 25 ans que
pascal nantais travaille en restauration
pour la première fois elle doit assumer
différents rôles sur le plancher on est
loin de l'époque où justement on avait
des piles 2cv qu'on avait l'embarras du
choix
on engage un put se pose y voit rentrer
le lendemain
maintenant c'est que ce moment le 5 le
climat de tout temps parc ne te faire
voile était cuisinier
salaires augmentent et assurances
bonifié mais cela ne suffit pas autre
défi l'hébergement
le marché immobilier de mont tremblant
est majoritairement locatif est réservé
aux touristes il existe peu de logements
disponibles et surtout abordable
on avait pu trouver des employés qui est
intéressé venaient travailler chez nous
ces gens là ont cherché de l'hébergement
à proximité et sa peau était possible
devant cette problématique parce qu'elle
a décidé d'acheter une maison de six
chambres pour loger ses futurs employés
on espère que ça soit un plus à trouver
du personnel qui provient de l'extérieur
on va conserver ses armes ici qu'ils
vont faire partie du capes autre
solution construire des logements
abordables
on est juste à peine 8 9 minutes de la
station
ce promoteur immobilier construire à 120
unités la première phase du campus ryan
un projet de 40 millions de dollars sera
complété en décembre 2022 l'objectif est
d'offrir des appartements à des prix
raisonnables
j'ai jamais vu un projet avant sécher
rapidement que celui ci les travaux ne
sont même pas encore commencé que
l'engouement se fait sentir
ça fait juste deux semaines qu'on a
commencé la liste d'attenté au dessus de
100 personnes se sont inscrites la
plupart des gens qui ont réservé à date
sont des employeurs de la région l'ours
qui est un modèle c'est que des projets
privés qui se décide il ya ce contrat
avec les vis d'un partenariat avec les
entreprises ici parce que les
entreprises ont une responsabilité
importante ou seeland c'est ben beau
d'investir dans le recrutement
l'attraction de la main d'oeuvre mais
cette époque avoir délogé aujourd'hui
des efforts ça donne rien la solution
passe peut-être par redéfinir les
modèles de développement économique
croit paul calce le secteur de
l'habitation le transport les écoles la
santé fait partie du développement
économique donc ça les municipalités
sont conscients de ça et ils veulent
participer mais pas à n'importe quel
prix parce que le citoyen qui paye en
arrière fait le citoyen dit moi je paye
des taxes à saint portant mais
l'employeur lui fait quoi donc c'est un
modèle qu'on est avantagé actuellement
ce qu'on n'a pas réussi présentement sur
l'étalement urbain tandis que pas
d'hébergement abordable on incite les
gens à aller s'installer justement
encore plus en périphérie donc on veut
éviter à tout prix
des mairies de la main d'oeuvre pénurie
de logements abordables et relance
économique
les défis seront nombreux pour les
prochains élus municipaux il si marine
celle aux ondes radio canada mont
tremblant
[Musique]